congresista republicanos terminaron
votando por la otra alternativa que se
conoció hoy que es el congresista
republicano Jim Jordan estas 20
republicanos pues le impiden a Kevin
mccarthy lograr este 218 votos
necesarios para poder ser confirmado
como presidente de la cámara de
representantes en reemplazo de Nancy
pelosi lo que argumentan muchos de ellos
y se conoció previa a esta votación de
hoy es que Kevin mccarthy es un
republicano del establecimiento que
representa las políticas viejas
republicanas que pues no han podido
lograr dejar avanzar una agenda más
radical que son la que apoyan estos 20
congresistas más radicales en
republicanos estos congresistas pues han
pedido por ejemplo reformas tributarias
que favorecen a las empresas han pedido
acciones en cuanto a la migración mucho
más severas que pues Kevin mccarthy no
les ha dado la seguridad para contar con
el voto y contar con su apoyo en esta
votación precisamente Esto fue lo que
hizo Kevin mccarthy días antes y horas
antes de esta votación
lograrás empezar a hacer concesiones a
este grupo de republicanos más extremos
más extremistas para poder contar con su
voto pero pues no se ha podido llegar a
un acuerdo lo que se va a hacer ahora
por parte del partido republicano es
juntarse lograr de limar esas asperezas
llegaron punto en común para no seguir
alargando esto Cristóbal Esta es una
situación inusual Cuántas votaciones se
pueden realizar
innumerables votaciones se pueden
realizar de hecho la última vez que Esto
ocurrió en 1903 se llevó a más de 120
votaciones dos meses sin presidente a la
cámara de representantes Así que esto se
podría alargar alargar Pues si nadie
sabe que podría pasar si no se ponen de
acuerdo los republicanos mañana mediodía
vuelve vuelve la plenaria de la cámara
de representantes y habrá una cuarta
votación sin embargo Pues hay mucha hay
mucha inseguridad y mucha incertidumbre
sobre lo que puede pasar y esto
obviamente pues afecta la imagen del
partido republicano que muestra sus
divisiones internas del ala más radical
apoyada por el expresidente Donald Trump
y de los republicanos que quieren llegar
a un acuerdo y quieren Mostrar cierta
solidez cierta unión para empezar a
gobernar y empezar precisamente a
avanzar en estas legislaciones que
quieren avanzar en estos proyectos de
ley que quieren llevar a cabo los
republicanos en la cámara de
precisamente con temas como la migración
como temas Fiscales y como temas a la
situación económica de Estados Unidos
que no es de menor importancia teniendo
en cuenta la inflación que vive el país